so it's interesting what you were
talking about earlier is in terms of
mental fortitude and your ability to
adapt and the ability to overcome I
wonder if we're ever gonna figure out a
way to measure that like to measure in
mental endurance or measure mental
capacity or mental stimulation you know
you can measure your vo2 max mm-hmm and
you know what the body's capable of but
I wonder if there's a way like when
someone does hear a great song and it
kicks in whether it's through fMRI or
any other type of detection device where
they can figure out a way oh this part
of your brain is firing let's
concentrate on building up the the
activation of that part of that brain of
the brain like like a muscle when like
think of that endurance or think of that
motivation as like maybe even a mantra
that you can call upon because you call
upon it all the time and you can
recreate that state yeah I mean I think
on on that point certainly over in
Britain at the moment so basically women
for the first time can actually apply
and be in the Special Forces so at the
moment it's really really interesting
because speaking to you certainly the
raw Marines they were saying we've got
hundreds of years that a few handers 500
young fit men we can say they need to be
this weight this tall and if you give us
them we've got years and years of
experience of putting them through this
training system of mental and physical
fortitude everything down in limb stone
it's the the the training center of the
raw Marines and we go on this endurance
course we go on a 30-mile jump with a
backpack everything and by the end of 32
weeks that's what it takes to be a real
marine to get your Green Beret after 32
weeks we can take you from being
completely knots identity but unfit to
being a raw marine and that's one thing
they pride themselves on but now what
they're saying is obviously you know
females can now apply to Special Forces
and what they find so interesting is and
I certainly do as well is what does that
look like for a female raw marine you
know what does that look like for things
on and again to go back I mean I wrote
an article a ages ago run like a girl
and I was saying I wanna run like a girl
you know someone some of my best
training partners a female
they their perception to fatigue is
unbelievable that's purely anecdotal but
also as well when you look at the top
tier of ultra marathon runners and
swimming as well
Diana and I eat first to go from Florida
to Cuba to Florida you know incredible
like she was getting stung by Portuguese
MANOWAR's and just unbelievable just
purely and it but now they're saying you
know why is it that that certain female
athletes have a greater tolerance e to
pain and I think to your point if we can
start to quantify that because there are
biological differences you take men you
know high testosterone can have an
impact on high hemoglobin generate
muscle force all of these things but but
I think if we could quantify why it is
that certain female athletes are
dominating the top 10% of ultra
marathons and open water swimming what
is it that they're doing that would be
amazing I think the ability to endure
pain and this is not my thought honestly
I should just say this has been
theorized before has to do with their
ability to endure the pain of childbirth
child labor and childbirth I mean just
the fact that they're forcing a baby out
of their vagina and yeah I mean that is
insane I mean you don't do oh you were
seeing the Machine they do they've taken
these electrodes they put it on men and
recreate the pain of childbirth yet and
watch these men fall apart like [ __ ]
turn it off yeah it's I mean obviously I
haven't given birth but it's supposed to
be unbelievably painful and women are
biologically suited to this this is like
so I think their ability to endure that
pain is just it's probably just there's
an evolutionary advantage to having this
more higher capacity but I also think
one of the things that I learned from
teaching martial arts is that women they
learn technique better many times than
men do because one they listen and two
they don't try to muscle things so women
have less of a problem with learning
something from a person and this is also
true about archery my friend John Dudley
who's an archery coach says his favorite
students are
always women because they listen better
they don't have as much of an ego they
don't have to pretend they already know
something they don't want to just try it
without they follow it to a tee better
like generally obviously we're speaking
in generalities but they also don't have
the extra muscle that a man has so men
are strong we'll try to just force
things and muscle things where women
will try to follow what's being
described to them what's the proper
technique and they knew it properly all
the time and then they develop this
pattern of proper technique I noticed
this with Taekwondo and I think my
friend John said he noticed this with
archery I think this this this benefits
them in sports because like if you learn
jujitsu really the best people to learn
from our smaller men or women because
they the smaller people they don't have
the physical strength to pull it off on
a big guy hmm so what they have to rely
on is correct technique mm-hmm but if
you learn jujitsu from a big guy man big
guy Jiu Jitsu is weird because they
could just grab your wrist and you can't
get go you can't let go and they can get
away with things like okay you go wrist
control and throw the legs up wrist
control okay wrist control on who where
I try wrist control on that big
[ __ ] that was rowing the world
record hey man you're gonna go flying
through the air that was totally gonna
work right you're gonna have to go
against his strength you're gonna have
to figure out a way to move around it
you're not have to go you're not gonna
go through it right that big guy if he
was teaching jujitsu I just grabbed her
neck and onions Cui's he's got the kind
of horsepower that a man like you know a
normal man can't imagine